what I've noticed is the men and women
are mad and they're mad for different
reasons okay the men say to the women
you guys aren't virgins anymore I mean
they won't tell you this to your face
but this is what they're thinking you're
not virgins anymore you guys are fat
you're not even loyal you get your ass
on Instagram and you're asking me to
marry you and the thing is most men want
to get married most men are willing to
marry girls a little overweight most men
are willing to marry a girl that has a
lot of body like honestly I'm just being
real here most men are gonna Overlook
that stuff it's not their preference but
most men and by a lot of bodies is
subjective but I'm saying by 1950
standards okay most men are gonna wife a
girl that slept with more than three
people